12 year NBA veteran and a man who is
closely associated with the Kentucky
Wildcat basketball program and has a
wildly popular and entertaining Twitter
feed he's none other than Rex Chapman -
Rex I was about to say what happened I
guess let's start with that macro
question involving Kentucky basketball
Rex well you know I think I think
experience caught up with the lack of
experience caught up with us
you know started four freshmen and
sophomores for most of the season and
ran into a hot team in Auburn we feed
him twice
we couldn't score we couldn't score down
the stretch guys guys have to make plays
there were enough there were enough
plays yesterday to be made to win that
game and we just couldn't make enough
shots or make enough play and I guess in
terms of Auburn basketball where do you
stand on the subject of the fact that
Chuck person is has his entire life on
the line right now legally and this team
is in the Final Four
the former Auburn assistant who has been
ensnared in the in the federal legal
sting yes the Chuck person yes sir yeah
yeah yeah how do I feel about it
yeah personally I don't care about any
of that
I really don't all these kids if they're
if they're all in the same 18 to 23 year
old window I don't care how they got
wherever they go if you got if you're
playing a 30 year old I got a problem
with that but hey I'm happy for Bruce
Pearl of course listen I've got I know
it's his family and kids a little bit
I'm just happy for Oliver and I'm happy
for Chuck Charles Barkley he started
this whole thing way back when and for
them to be in the Final Four you know as
an SEC guy and as a friend it's just I'm
really happy for him
yeah I know Charles was Charles Barkley
was ecstatic we could see that I mean he
oh yeah he was just losing his mind
which is the best team that still
remains now
now that obviously got a red-hot Auburn
team and Virginia moving forward in
breathtaking fashion against Purdue
which is the best team still remaining
here Rex you know I don't know I think
that you know at this point it's one
game you can beat anybody I think that
the Michigan State may have the best the
toughest team to be able to play any way
you want to play slows a store whatever
I think that Texas Tech has the best
player and then Virginia I'm really
happy for Tony Bennett those guys what a
disappointing season they had last year
getting beat by 16 you know they've got
some real talent they got a big kid
who's great talented guard this is a
it's a toss-up for me you know I'm gonna
pay less attention now that my guys are
out of there and in fact yesterday for
real I was so despondent after our game
that I turned off the Duke game at
halftime went to sleep
took a nap woke up to found that found
out they'd gotten beat thinking that
might make me feel better
and and it made me feel worse thinking
we could be there in the Final Four and
Duke not be there that's the way you
actually felt about all that cuz you
know it's interesting Rex you're the
perfect person to ask this then in that
regard what are you saying that you
would make you feel better that Duke
wasn't in you know my ten-year-old son
who just beat me and the rest of the
crew here in our bracket knowing I'm a
Michigan fan watching me root for
Michigan State in that game
ask me why I hated Duke so much and I
don't really have an answer for him Rex
yeah why we don't either and here's the
thing I I like all the guys that almost
every guy that's ever going to do I
really like Coach K I think he's
fantastic
I have friends Johnny Dawkins one of my
good buddy Jay Bilas all those guys they
will love all those guys I just can't
then Jude and the idea of Duke I don't
even know what that means
I can't stand it no you know I yeah
that's disappointing I wanted to see
that they kiss
to play again I feel like either you
know generational type of player so I'm
a little disappointed for them but I'm
not gonna lose too much sleep over it
yeah I bet I know so I mean obviously
you got reddish you have obviously Zion
and and Barrett is this is this a
failure of a season for Duke I hate to
be so so you know black and white here
because normally I do like to live in
the gray area that there's not
everything is one thing or the other in
sports but you've got this collection of
freshman talent that is so unique and
Duke didn't even make the final four
where do you stand on that subject Rex
how do you let me just ask you the
question rich because it's what I think
about when you ask how do you view the
John Calipari 38 no team that was beaten
by Wisconsin in the Final Four
right how I'm asking you how do you feel
about that you feel like that was a
complete utter failure no I do not mind
it I kind of do and so therefore I look
at this this year and I go yeah come on
if you've got three of the top five or
six guys you're supposed to win I guess
what I don't get and maybe it's just my
I'm hypersensitive for the Kentucky you
know sort of critique is it's it's okay
taking as much grease today as Cal is I
don't know I know in our neck of the
woods
Cal's taking a lot of grease but I it
seems that maybe cows hurricane's being
treated with a little kinder gloves
after this and how might be is that
right well I mean he has taken Duke to a
dozen Final Fours he would have just
brie would have broken the record that
he's tied with John Wooden with had this
team beaten Michigan State yesterday
maybe maybe there's that but you you
explain to me what why is Cal getting
heat in Kentucky well right now I'm in
cows been there ten years been in the
Elite Eight what eight times Final Four
four or five times one one I just don't
get it it seems like it seems like back
in the day few years ago that was
everything that was wrong with with
college basketball on and done and all
that
and then Jay started doing the
one-and-done started going after those
guys and I'm just you know he's won one
since then but one I just I don't
understand I feel like there's just a
little different set of rules for talent
there as opposed to K and I know that
they're different types of coaches but
they're Hall of Famers I just don't get
the uber crit critical narrative on on
Chow all the time when it clinic you
know if they went to the Elite Eight
with four freshmen and sophomore sorry
come on what Rex Chapman here on the
Rich Eisen show so you say Jared
Culver's the best player still left
that's the player from Texas Tech that
you're referring to yeah I think their
guy is really good and listen there
they've got another little guard that's
really good
plays alongside him Eric terrific
defensive team coach has done a terrific
job this year had getting any of these
teams can win at this point what do you
think what do you think of Carson
Edwards at Purdue I know what he was
lighting it up man fantastic I'm I'm you
know the white Kemble was controlling
everybody play back when he's he's small
but man he's a competitor and can put it
in the basket
what a fun fun team to watch what's the
best shooting night you ever had Rex oh
my gosh man I have no idea a making
night or shooting night making night Rex
making night I love it yeah making night
where you were I mean the kid climbed
from Purdue on on Thursday night and
then Carson Edwards on Saturday it was
just it's just awesome to watch just so
much fun it's what the tournament is
truly all about what what what's your
best making night were it looked like
you were throwing it into the ocean man
I don't even know it's been so long ago
I think that you have those nights from
time to time I probably had a few of
Mythology off him in the NBA where you
just feel like you know everything you
shoot
I think the fun part about it is you
know you're ready for that you put in
thousands of shots and spent the time in
the gym
I know people people will ask those
questions like what do you I don't look
at it the same way you know you put the
work in you feel like you belong there
and it's all kind of a blur 30 years
later 20 years later or whatever it is
but it sure as fun watching these young
guys now I don't know I look back they
do so much stuff better than we all did
with our offhand they can go no to their
opposite hand so much more than we all
could the way they can these guys can
fly down the court breakneck speed--
pulled up on balance and shoot over you
know on the run three pointer or
shooting three-pointers all the time off
the dribble with high success it's a
different game than when I played man so
a couple more minutes left here with Rex
Chapman on the Rich Eisen show you
saying that inexperience caught up with
Kentucky the greatest freshman team
perhaps since the Fab five didn't even
make the final four is his experience
overlooked here Rex that we're talking
about all these won and Duns and how
they are helpful to collegiate programs
are we seeing the other way around right
now you know I think I'm not exactly
sure how to answer that question but I
do think this we can go back and yes the
games different now the rules are
different
someone put out a picture yesterday of
the 1984 Final Four it was a Sports
Illustrated picture it had Wayman
Tisdale and Michael Jordan and Chris
Mullin and up 10 guys from that year Sam
Perkins these were all three and
four-year guys that were in that picture
college guys and if you go back 19
year-olds are still 19 and when you get
into it I was much better as a player
when I was 20 then I was when I was 17
just getting on Kentucky's campus and
people thought I was good then and I was
it I mean I was but I couldn't have
played in the NBA not at the 17 18 year
old I could 2 years later so any age is
it's a factor not many of us are LeBron
or Sion or
you know Kobe or Katie or those guys and
those guys are different um you know
youth you got to be really special we
wanted a few years ago with the top two
picks in the draft in check Michael
kidd-gilchrist and Anthony Davis and but
we had it we had a senior on that P man
Darius Miller every team that we've had
that's really made a deep run has a
balance on it of some experience and I
think that you yes experience is always
overlooked you can't have enough of it
last thing for you Rex I'd be remiss if
I did not bring up again I mentioned
your money or more you're AB one or more
entertaining Twitter feeds and the block
or charge I guess the the bit that you
find some of the most violent I guess
videos involving human beings running
into things and you ask if it's a block
or a charge it is what where did you
come up with this idea how did it all
start with you well first I'm an idiot
at all I saw video of a dolphin swimming
in to see a school of dolphin swimming
in towards the shore and a guy on a
paddleboard getting out the dolphin hit
the guy square into myself
the idiot that I am with a ha that the
charge and kind of asked the question on
Twitter and people thought it was funny
that's it that's it there's nothing more
to it down as low as form of
entertainment see this one we're seeing
a panda hitting some poor young lady
standing top rope that's a charge well
she was she was she wasn't moving right
is that what I think the interpretation
everybody's got their interpretation of
what happened and nobody's right
nobody's calling are people sending new
ideas now rest easy now it's easy 20 20
videos
choose from from followers or friends
that have said oh you got to see this so
it's easy now it is amazing it's fun my
wife loves it everyone for the whole
family Rex I'll be honest well I step
over the line from time to time and have
to undo some tweets that I did because
people will get offended and a lot of
times I won't mind but I do try to cut
the videos off before we know if the
person actually lives you're a
humanitarian at heart Rex your
humanitarian hey enjoyed it I just enjoy
our chats all the time thanks for
calling and Rex sorry about sorry about
your team oh good thanks man we'll
reload be back next year you go that's
Rex Chapman at Rex Chapman on Twitter so
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience